una justicia que llega a 13 años tarde
era la Consigna de este hombre padre de
una de las 228 fallecidas del vuelo
af447
perdimos a nuestra hija y su prometido
ambos de 29 años
un gran sufrimiento por parte de ambas
familias pero el tiempo cura la herida
sin embargo todavía sentimos que aún no
se ha hecho justicia
para los familiares de las víctimas ya
es un logro haber llegado hasta esa
instancia Y es que hubo que revertir una
decisión judicial de 2019 para abrir
este proceso contra Air France y airbus
dos firmas insignias de Francia las
cajas negras y evidenciaron que los
pilotos reaccionaron de manera
equivocada a un problema relacionado con
los sistemas anti hielo en las salas y
que provocó una situación de bloqueo de
la aeronave el resultado una caída libre
contra el Océano Atlántico en medio de
una tormenta el francés asegura que una
serie de alarmas confusas abrumaron a
los pilotos herbas dice que fue un error
de los pilotos muchos interrogantes en
torno a un equipo que sumaba más de
20.000 horas de vuelo juntos este lunes
ambas empresas reiteraron su inocencia
vine hoy a expresar el nombre de Air
France nuestra más profunda compasión
con los familiares de las víctimas
dije lo que tenía que decir intenté ser
tan sincero como fue posible en relación
con lo que ocurrió
unos 50 ha llegados de las víctimas
hicieron parte de la apertura de este
juicio Habrá más de 470 testimonios hoy
uno a uno se leyeron los nombres de los
228 fallecidos se espera que el juicio
se extienda por nueve semanas y cada
compañía se enfrenta a una multa de
225.000 euros el equivalente a lo que
Air France ganaba en cinco minutos en
tiempos pruebandémicos o lo que hervas
sumaba en ganancias en dos minutos